What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Today we are going to find out
With how many balls we can play at the same
time
Let's start off with 2 balls.
I think that was too easy for us.
Let's do it with 3.
That was easier than it was with 2!
Miikka, do you think we can do it with 4 balls?
For sure we can.
Why didn't you hit them?
That went quite well.
Okay, so 4 was fairly easy.
Now, let's try with 5 balls.
Do you think it's possible?
I really don't know.
Let's see.
Magnificent!
Marvellous!
That was pretty good!
I mean, just look at that beard.
If you want to have as good feeling as me
You should rub your racket in my beard.
Emil, should we try 6?
I think we should give it a go.
There is no way this is going to work out.
So close!
Not, not bad enough.
Not bad?
Not bad enough!
We have to go even worse!
We have to get worse!
We are too good!
You got it?
We had it!
That was... good enough!
Was it ok?
I think it was!
I think it was good for my part.
For your part, yeah!
So this was our best shot
Of playing with as many balls as possible.
Hope you enjoyed it!
Remember to subscribe here
And watch our previous videos there.
Until next time!